hello and welcome to my talk today I am
a news watch ready
I'm a senior data scientist in the
Microsoft's algorithm and data science
group and we are a partner facing group
and we actually try and develop
algorithms to solve to solve problems
which are very customer specific
problems using machine learning and
other other algorithmic approaches so
today I'll be talking about deep
learning that's my area of 40 and I'll
be showing you how transfer learning and
fine tuning deep convolutional neural
networks can lead to reusability of the
model that you train so just give out a
small talk outline so I'll touch on
traditional machine learning and I'll
discuss how traditional machine learning
is different from deep learning then
we'll discuss why deep learning is at
all needed and then we'll dive deep into
deep convolutional networks transfer
learning of fine tuning of deep
convolutional networks will move on to
record neural networks and I'll use two
case studies to show you the reusability
of a deep learning model so first you
start with what is machine learning are
we commonly known as mo so machine
learning and creative analytics are the
core capabilities which drive business
decisions so people nowadays it's not
depending on any domain people use
machine learning to some extent or the
other so let's take the example of any
retail customer they use recommendation
engine to some extent or to a very very
detailed extent like context space and
stuff like that so the if you're any
retail customer you have to use machine
learning recommendation to some extent
or the other we have been hearing more
predictive analytics and machine
learning for a long time
but it's very difficult to actually work
with unstructured data like images texts
it requires any of your additional
machine learning algorithms it requires
your data processing in a particular
format so you need to spend a lot of
time preparing your data in this today
in today's world where we are generating
data by second and like loads and loads
of data we need much higher computation
power so it should be able to get the
raw data inside somehow apply the
machine learning algorithm and then give
out the analysis results to you so let's
take the example of vision analytics
right people have been using machine
learning with vision for over very long
all right okay that's good
otherwise I'll be just repeating what
you have done okay feel free to
interrupt me at any point of time need
not wait until the end okay so I was
talking about vision and analytics okay
so people actually have been using
images for a long time with machine
learning algorithms but it requires a
very intensive pre-processing step so
like take the example of medical images
people have been using the traditional
SVM algorithm for a long time to
classify to classify actually the
diseases from from any medical image but
it is a huge process if you go and
search for papers and PubMed there are
lots and lots of papers which tell you
how to get how to pre-process the image
filter apply filter get rid of the noise
and it's it's a whole study in itself
the whole image processing thing so just
to actually make it more simple and with
the advent of more computation power
that is with the advent of NVIDIA GPUs
we can now use a long existing like it
was existing deep learning algorithms
are nothing new it was existing for a
long time now even before I was born so
bu people are now being able to use it
to the full extent and actually reduce
the time required to compute and train
this complex data
okay let's formalize what I said
traditional machine learning requires
manual feature extraction and
engineering so I think my previous
speaker actually spoke about manual
feature extraction and engineering so
and you all are about a bear of it so
and feature extraction for unstructured
data is very complex as I just explained
it's very very complex it takes a lot of
time and a lot of subject-matter
expertise deep learning can
automatically learn features in it as
well automatically in codes because
obviously you need to give some kind of
manual intervention in there that's what
the that's what that's where your
expertise in designing the other girl
the network comes in like how many
layers
you need what kind of Oh what kind of
network you need that's where it comes
in but definitely we can absolutely skip
the manual feature extraction step deep
learning is a largely black box
techniques if you do not want to learn
about the network at all you can just
use it just like a just like a black box
I mean you can what we are trying to do
here in Microsoft as we are trying to
give out ATS have you guys heard of
cognitive api's no right so yeah it's a
very new thing the cognitive maybe and
the bot framework are two new things
which Microsoft has come up with and
there are all of our deep learning
algorithms running at the back end so
you can just call those api's and just
train use it just as any software
developer would be able to use it so
I'll talk about it I'll show you some
demos if I have time so let's stick with
it for the theoretical part before we
get to the front part so it updates the
the deep learning the deep neural
network updates learned waits at each
layer so it learns in layers that's why
it's more efficient more accurate so why
do we need deep learning for immigrants
it's the things which I said image data
request subject matter expertise to
extract feed for key features it takes
deep learning various extracts it
automatic automatically from any
domain-specific languages without any
feature engineering technique so this
makes the image analysis process much
easier so imagine you are not a person
who has and in any kind of ballet
biology background so you do not know
anything about medicine you do not know
anything about angiography MRI anything
okay so now you're given some MRIs or
some angiographic images so then you
said hey let can you draw some analysis
out of it can you tell me if this person
has diabetic retinopathy or not or
whether if this person is more prone to
having stroke or not so as an engineer
we all need to be ready for anything
like that deep learning has made this
thing much much easier all these people
let me go to the early work stuff so
first it first
something like neural
working in the paper in neo cognate Ron
you can go back and refer to the papers
it's very interesting read and then
young like whom actually in 1889 first
came up with the concept of
convolutional neural networks with the
advent of GPU so these were there for a
very long time it's just that our
computation power was not that efficient
to actually implement in a large-scale
basis with the advent of the GPUs and
and actually faithfully and Brian
Catanzaro of Nvidia they actually
jointly developed CUDA and kuhnian and
packages for specifically for deep
learning and that has made that is
actually the reason behind the
popularity of today's steep learning
algorithms so the most popular obviously
is the Alex net which was trained on
image net images actually the the best
part about it was it was trained on
Katherine cafe models ooh made the
trained weights are publicly available
so you can actually go to Katherine
model Zoo and download the image Nate
train so image net is a data set of
thousand images natural images like any
seen scenery and then there is animals
there is cars there is clothes any
natural image that you can think of not
any special image in matter remember
there is nothing like an geographic
image no MRI no CT scan no nothing like
that no special domain specific image or
any natural image like thousand of them
level trained images were actually
trained for many days and the network
Alex really created was Alex net so that
was that became very popular and the
trained waves were actually made public
that has actually that actually brings
me to my topic of transfer learning and
fine tuning how we can utilize so it's
really very difficult to train the
initial layers of a deep learning deep
convolution Network layer because you
need to it can scale up and this
overflow it can just clear down and
never converge so the initial weights
depending is depends a lot on your data
if you have some trained apes trained
data trained weights to be
used as your initial weights it actually
helps the model to converge much earlier
so that's where the transfer learning
comes right so we transfer some learning
some previous learnings into our new of
domain-specific model which we are going
to create and we fine-tune fine-tune is
changing the network so for image net
David thousand labels South thousand
output labels now what we say okay we do
not want thousand we just want to
predict if it's a cat or a dog just two
of them just add a binary classifier at
the end of the network and then mam you
have cats and dogs and you need to
modify your network accordingly so but
you keep all the states exactly the same
just your input source changes and you
change the classifier so instead of
thousand now you're doing a binary
classification at the end of your
network okay so let's do some formal
definitions so what does deep neural
network it trains networks and many
layers so multiple layers work to build
an improved feature space so obviously
we learn in layers so we learn lots and
lots of feature over time the first
layer learns the first order of features
so this is very important in our
fine-tuning tasks so what I say is in
there are different layers so for the
first is you're getting some input
inside and the first layer actually
learns only about colors very basic
about the image the colors the ages the
keystrokes the hue those kind of stuff
and to me there is no such color
difference between domain-specific image
and a natural image Orange is an orange
everywhere okay it's just that if I have
a geographic image I'll have almost the
whole images Orange whereas I have a
natural image of a person wearing an
orange t-shirt that will be just the
person's body upper part of the body
saying it's orange so it's very easy to
actually get the color perceptions out
so if so so now I ask you if I mean if
I've trained my model on a natural
language that are natural images now if
I keep the first layers fixed
and find you the lower list which
becomes more domain-specific that
suffice is right I mean it has already
learned about the color the stroke and
everything so I just I need not train
the whole eight layers
I'll just train the last four or five
layers maybe so let's see how I do it
so this so the second layer onwards it
learns to higher-order features okay and
lastly the final layer features are fed
into supervised layers as I said it is
already being fed into a rail you or a
softmax classifier you can add another
binary classifier on top of it whatever
suits your need okay so a deep
convolutional neural network this is how
traditionally the model looks like so
that's the input okay I was told to move
the mouse pointer so this is the input
image and these are the convolution
layers from the convolution there you
actually downsample to the to the
pooling layer and then you again move
out to the second layer of so what
happens if convolutional air is it
learns in two stages first it tries to
apply a filter or rate to every
convolution layer and then it goes to
the end of the network okay and then it
does a back propagation it it actually
learns when it does a back propagation
where it has made some changes based on
the features that was available at the
end and it tries to modify the filter
accordingly then it takes in the next
segment input data and tries to apply it
to the modified back propagation filter
it and then again it comes back and sees
how it needs to modify the weight or the
filter so the backward in the forward
propagation is something initially I was
talking about deep neural at four this
is deep convolutional network learn new
neural networks so it be learned forward
propagation and backward propagation two
stages
okay so let's yes
so that's what what the initial weights
were weights are I said right in it is
very much image dependent so you that's
where the expertise of a model maker or
a data scientist comes and where you
actually have to initialize the weight
crank correctly if you do not use it
correctly there's a chance that after 15
15 iterations it will just overflow it
overflows a memory or after after even
15,000 iterations it never converges so
it's very essential to actually do the
do the correct that's the step we
actually trying to skip by using the
transfer learning so that anybody I mean
not even not a data scientist who do not
have any algorithmic experience can
actually use deep learning to make a
software development application ok yes
no computer what I do not understand
what you mean by computational intensive
but there is a new thing which came up
in Nvidia they introduced something
called obedient and it's a very new
paper and they actually have reduced the
competition by almost seven to eight
times by introducing seven by the entry
DNN so just go and read about it it is
actually so I'll just touch it so what
you do is when you learn you produce
lots and lots of image features right
every convolution layer it actually
increases multiple times the the
features that you are producing out what
Radian and does is actually copies it
through the PCI to the memory and keeps
it there and while and it frees up a lot
of memory space so that it performs much
better it's way more faster when it's
coming back it brings back the Bradbury
it's on demand so it's a completely
architectural thing so and and it's it's
really interesting how I knew it but
yeah let's talk about that later
so that's yes oh the deep stands for so
the question was what is the deep stands
for in deep convolution Network so if
it's more than two layers of convolution
it's called deep that's what I'm saying
if there are two convolutional neural
Nets then it's called convolutional
neural Nets if there are more than two
convolutional layer it's called deep
convolution on there okay so there are
there are two main features in a
convolutional inner it's called
convolution and it's pooling okay let's
look at them so this is how a
convolution is working in the left image
so this is an input image and this is a
feed filter that is the weight as I said
you apply and you try to do multiplying
it right so this because this place is
just the one it's only 42 is is a valid
number which can
out of it right everything becomes
sparse because I multiply all the
numbers with zero right and that's how
we create a huge sparse matrix right
that is the and we take each and every
segment so like we take the first four
and then the next four and we then take
the next four and we take it in segments
and that's why when we do a convolution
there if the input image is like this we
get like eight or sixteen depending on
the squares that we are selecting okay
and convolution layers consist of
rectangular grid of neurons so we call
these neurons the weights for this are
the same for each neuron in the
convolution layer the convolution layer
weights specify the convolution filter
as I just said this is this is these are
called abates or the filter they are
interchangeably used okay let's go to
pooling the pooling layer takes small
rectangular blocks from the convolution
in there and sub-samples it to produce a
single output from that block so here we
are doing max pooling so what I'm doing
is there's a first rectangle so I'm
pulling the first one out so it's six
and on the second rectangle the max one
out eat from third one the yellow it's
the three and from the blue one it's
four okay
so that way we're just down sampling so
we have actually blown up our feature
space by magnitudes but because we
multiplied it by feature vectors right
but by weights so now we need to down
sample it that's the what the pooling
layer is a down sampler that's why we
learn in cycles right that's why it's
not just one thing we take so when he
learns it it's your face it's learning
about you just take this part of the
pixel first then learn about it then it
take the next pixel and it does like it
takes like small rectangular portions
where there are a small amount of pixels
and it learns recursively that's why
it's that's why it takes so long to
train a neural network any deep neural
network because the deeper it is that
there are more convolution and pooling
and you are going precise that's why it
increases deep deep ones are more
precise than the natural ones as she was
asking so why he used it because it's
more
accurate it's more precise but the
drawback it takes a long time to
actually train it how do we improve it
by transfer learning and fine tuning
because we are using the image we are
keeping the initial errors fixed so we
need less layers to modify okay we are
if there it's a 16 it's a video Ginette
it's a 16 layers or 19 layers it takes
forever I mean I tried it you using a 4
GB in Theano I tried with a 4 GB GPU I
couldn't train it at minimum requires 24
GB memory capacity for a GPU so you can
only train it on a GPU cluster so that's
why if you're using a already trained
vgg net that is possible using a 4gb GPU
so that's actually giving you the
performance as well as accuracy okay so
this is young the Koons a model this is
just a DC n n sample if you have a
handwritten digit out there the 32
across 32 input image you actually blow
it out by convolution and then down
sample it and from the from the s2 layer
here I'm multiplying it with uh with the
sparse matrix and then I'm getting c3 so
I'm multiplying cs2 with sparse metric
like this and I'm getting this 16 layers
right so I have 6 down sampled layer and
then multiplying it again and getting 16
convolution layer and again I do some
sound sampling and I continue doing this
in different cycles ok transfer learning
and fine tuning convolution neural
network this is this is an image taken
from again as proposed his paper so it
has been trained on thousands to
millions of labeled images and as you
can see there are multiple outputs
essentially there are thousand outputs
of image net so it's car truck cat dog
by cycle by then then whatever like a
hat or dress things like that there are
multiple categories suppose you want to
learn only about car and truck or cat
and dog or cat dog bird not only binary
any number of times any number of output
but just not thousand maybe
less maybe more I mean you can actually
blow it up too but but the thing is we
actually use the pre chain to CNN and
use it as an initial rate and then we
fine-tune the network weights but we are
we are actually training fewer networks
because we have fixed some weights and
we are doing the transfer learning here
okay let's see what actually I'm using
what framework so there are many many
deep learning frameworks available
nowadays the oak I will be talking about
the open source ones so there are non
symbolic frameworks and symbolic
frameworks the non the main drawback of
non symbolic or imperative frameworks
are torch which are like torch cafe they
are the it's actually because manual
optimization so it's not very as helpful
if you if you want to modify it right in
transfer learning you want to modify it
so if you are using cafe or torch it's
it's not very easily modifiable so it's
fine if you just you have a trained
model and you're just testing on that
train model it will work maybe better
than piano maybe much better than Theano
but the problem with cafe or torch is it
is very hard to modify symbolic
frameworks like piano tensorflow c NT k
microsoft deep learning framework MX net
which supports are are actually can
infer optimization automatically from
the dependency graph and the symbolic
framework can exploit much more memory
reuse so is easily modifiable
the memory is reusable and there are
many more other plus points I'll be
using piano for my work here
so it's easy to implement to create new
networks and also to modify existing
networks it has got high-level language
support its was godless non Ian cars so
it's a it is if you are a Python user if
you're even if you're a Python developer
you can just go and play with it and
modify it very easily
you need not understand unlike tensors
and the multi-pronged approach that can
actually actually trigger your brain a
little bit but yeah you
need not touch that it's very easy to
just modify using the Python there if
you use especially if you're using
carols it's easy to customize in a very
domain-specific yet I'll show you and
transfer learning and fine tuning is
very easy because it's very easy
modifiable so the first case study which
I will talk about is the damn dick
Retina Patek prediction if you're a
casual user you must have seen this data
multiple times if not welcome it's a
very heavily used sample data set from
kaggle we use labelled fluorescent and
geographic images of eyes to improve a
verdict retinopathy prediction so lets
me talk a little bit about diabetic
retinopathy so 80% of the vision loss in
America is due to damaged retinopathy
people who get diabetes actually are our
ranch person prone to get a verdict
retinopathy prediction and complete
vision loss so it's very essential to
actually try and predict diabetic
retinopathy at a much earlier stage
there are four stages of diabetic
retinopathy so it's mild medium high and
prolific once its prolific you lose your
vision so it's very essential that you
start your treatment in mild or medium
stage pass the medium stage the actually
the treatment does not work that well so
Florence's angiography is nothing but
they inject a dye called fluorescent in
your eyes and it dilates the blood
vessels so if there is a rupture so
basically what happens in diabetic
retinopathy is it actually Dalits and
ruptures and your eyes bleed and there
is complete vision loss so it can look
at the diameter of the when you give the
dye you can separate you can actually
look at the diameter of the blood
vessels and how dilated they are so
that's how you actually recognize at
which stage of diabetic retinopathy your
patient is in and we'll use a convulsion
neural network to improve this tablet be
written about the prediction will use
Google net again a very commonly used a
network by Google it was built on top of
inspired by Lynette and it's performs
better I think it performs better there
is an
I use an image net pre-trained Google
net so image net are these natural
images flower animals ships pumpkin
Halloween pumpkins dogs so these are
actually on the on the Left it's the
prediction accuracy so if you upload a
picture of a leopard it actually
currently says leopard and the second
highmost prediction is Jaguar so it's
not saying just a cat so it's it learns
pretty accurately because Jaguar and
leopards are different in their patterns
of the black spots and it can go to that
front fine-grain of the picture and
understand how different the black spots
are and actually can say whether if it's
a Jaguar or a leopard
so me and Microsoft have been using this
this mechanism to verify which are the
male and the female giraffes so there is
pattern there is the red they have
different public spot patterns so it was
very becoming essential for national
park in Iran and Africa to actually
track their white a female giraffe
population is going down so we actually
so there is a blog available and how
they have done it so definitely go and
check it out
so transfer learning and fine tuning our
deep learning model so we use first
image net trainer a pre trained model we
fine-tune that D CNN to transfer
generally learned feature to diabetic
retinopathy prediction the lower layers
of the pre train d CNN content generic
features that can be used by the dr
prediction task let's look at it so just
by looking at it you cannot say right
which one is to have the correct and up
a pic and which one is not I mean the
one on this one looks like it's more
dilated more spotty so you can say it's
taptic retinopathy but so is this one
right so you cannot say that there's
this pair is diabetic retinopathy
acordes pair so oh no I'll show you it
just just give me a minute the upper
layer whole of them are diabetic
retinopathy even this one is diabetic
retinopathy and the lower layer
everything is non-diabetic ratna pathak
even the one which is spotty
right so it depends
actually it depends on the fine dilation
of the blood vessel which is not
actually very easily perceived by
national human eyes obviously doctors
are trained for for many many years they
could me that's why we go to doctors and
show them our MRIs or angiographic
images but we cannot say which one is
what even if the machine is predicting
wrong you cannot say what it is
predicting wrong whether if it's correct
or not so it's very essential to do it
very correctly almost close to hundred
percent - because it's medical data and
the medical analysis will depend on it
so there is no filtering process there
is no noise cancelling there is no
application of colored filter we want to
keep the color intact right but the
problem one very big problem of deep
learning is it requires lots and lots of
data to be trained ok it requires a huge
because imagine it is million images
it's very difficult to get like labelled
domain specific images so it's its spot
it's not possible I mean I I can say
that this is maybe the only diabetic
retinopathy image set which they have
created and made open source in cattle
even if it is it's very it has got PII
gay tides held respectively by by
hospital so we have a heart stroke data
which we work with in Texas hospital but
its proprietary they do not release it
so it's very difficult to get very very
small domain specific data set so what
we do is we augment the image and
increase the carpus size by augmentation
I mean I just rotate the images okay so
there is zero degree I make 90 degree
270 degree 180 degree and then 270
degree so by just rotating the images
and it's very essential if you're
learning about humans right if I stand
like this my hands are up and my legs
are down if I show a pic and I train
only on me standing upright and then I
show as a test image I show my computer
of me standing on my hands which I
cannot but still yeah I am standing on
my hands and it will say oh hey I think
this is the legs and this is that this
is the hands and this is
legs because it knows that direction and
orientation only so it's very essential
to make your model very very accurate to
use image augmentation so it learns in
different angles and the colors also
depend in different angles so it differs
so it learns colors hues and different
angles yes yes so I have used 24 cross
24 but yeah I think that is the minimum
one should go to so that you retain the
original color and the hue the intensity
and everything
you can obviously train smaller but
obviously if your data in is bad then
your data out will not be that much
accurate right the smallest one which
which we do I mean which we upload in
the cognitive API switch where we have
made public is 50 cross 50 but 20 I have
used 24 cross 24 and has worked really
well still so it varies I would suggest
not going below 24 cross 24 and also not
use thousand by thousand because it will
take like forever to train your neural
Lattimore because it takes the image in
segments right in pixel segments so so
do not use thousand by thousand maybe 50
by 50 or or maybe hundred by hundred is
the max you can use okay depends
actually if you are really if you have a
huge GPU cluster I'm talking about
individual contributors if you have a
huge GPU cluster so I used to work for a
supercomputer Center and we had a we had
a this big GPU cluster and it was it was
a supercomputer so if you have something
like that available obviously go ahead
and use thumbs on by thousand whatever
you want but but just for individual
contributors or to get something done
very quickly definitely a smaller size
picture but get retaining the
information is very important and that's
where you need to take the call
yes now Yuri keep the aspect ratio you
keep so the so the essential thing is to
keep the aspect ratio same do not change
the aspect ratio if you change that
aspect ratio you change there is a
chance of you know get losing in one
data in one dimension so whatever way
you shrink your data like you you
actually obviously in the case of 98
person you will get 97 or 96 percent
accuracy but that's the that's the you
know compromise you're making so that
you can complete your task in time okay
does that was image augmentation how
much time I have
oh my five minutes okay I'll try to go
fast okay so this is where I'm doing
transfer learning so here it's zero
Degree the red one the green one is 90
degree this one is purple one is 180
degrees and 270 B so I input images in
multiple dimensions and try to this is
convolution pooling convolution pooling
and then I apply a binary classifier
here and I get diabetic retinopathy
on--don't diabetic retinopathy okay so
this transfer learning because I keep
the initial rate same here and then I
apply the final layers I change okay
okay thanks I come to fine tuning okay
so I fixed the first two convolution
there's because I said I'll be using the
image net trained initial weights so I
fixed the first two convolutional layers
then I fine-tune all other layers and
then I add new layer for a binary
classification and that's how I'm
getting non diabetic retinopathy and
death diabetic retinopathy okay
that's all I'm changing yes
yes the lower layers that's what I said
there wasn't it was in the slide so you
need to keep the lower layers because
that's the first layers you hit and
those are the layers that takes most of
the time to get trained because it's
good seeing an image for the first time
and it tries to those are the layers
which actually learns about colors key
strokes angles and things like that and
because it has no prior knowledge about
the images those are the layers actually
takes most of the time to learn or to
train so if you fix the way those layers
there and train the so it has some prior
knowledge about okay if I see this
pattern this is this is blue this is
green and it knows what the pattern to
look for yes but that's the input that
when I say fix I say the weights the
weights of it yes yes I do not do a
forward and backward propagation on on
the on the weight images but obviously
the input is is coming and feeding and
the multiplication is banged in done by
already pre paint filters or weights
okay okay this is dab de [ __ ] no
Pathak prediction outcome so I tried all
the green ones where they were it was
able to create or predict diabetic
retinopathy correctly and all the red
ones it did wrong it said no it's not
diabetic retinopathy so as you can see
out of like two I actually gave 25 but
out of hundred images only three were
wrong so that is that is a good
percentage that I was getting and the
more you train you more get get more
accuracy so this was the first I think I
trained it for for I think 50 iterations
and this was the outcome yes
24 by 24 yes 24 by 24 like like analysts
yes like amnesty I said really low but
as I said if you keep the aspect ratio
correct and it it took me about a week
to train it but I because I was using
just one GPU or 4gb if you if you are
using multiple GPS you would be able to
train it within three days I'm hoping so
and that's not bad
to get 96% accuracy with that yes not
with the dr about the one which we
worked on the with the texas hospital
the the stroke data which is not public
yes obviously you need a ground truth
and in in in medical image analysis
doctors are the ground truth so yes yes
yes it can it kind of because it learns
in iterations and it learns multiple
times and it auto corrects itself as it
learns so our d CNN improves dr
prediction accuracy compared to the
state of the art obviously to answer you
come back to your question if you
increase the image resolution obviously
it will get to the security much more
faster but then to train it over a
bigger network layer it will take a lot
of time ok so you need more computation
power to to come to this accuracy in the
same amount of time if you increase the
computation power it will work ok so our
decision and improves the our prediction
accuracy compared to the
state-of-the-art
SVM approaches so people have been using
as vm you can find papers in pubmed yes
that's a good question yes yes yes yes
yes the it was it was it was the balance
was it was not a good balance data so we
had to we had to balance it by taking
like almost equal proportions trying to
get like it like if I take 25% of
diabetic retinopathy I try to take 75%
of non diabetic retinopathy because
there are no more cases of non diabetic
retinopathy than diabetic retinopathy so
that's why I was trying to predict and
see if it's can correctly predict
diabetic retinopathy right because
because it can learn it can over fit or
non diabetic retinopathy instead of
diabetic retinopathy yes it is a
disposition and and I took that one and
plotted it too but but I am here just
showing you the mean accuracy I mean
that's what people mostly generally
relate to right even if you're showing
it to your doctors they're like oh
what's the curacy level of your model so
like that's that's most people yeah so
when you're showing it to your end
customer or your end users that's the
best thing which they understand it
they're not they're not yes separate
separate yes sorry oh that's what I said
I tried to I tried to balance it I tried
to balance it yes manually do it and
select this person and this person and
then try to test it I mean there is a
validation set and then when I so I
tried to test it train it and then use a
balance to validation set and then
change the network accordingly if it if
it did not do well I mean it needed to
increase the training set once or twice
so that it becomes more balanced and
then when I tested it on the test set
the results at answering that's the
result I got you okay other uses of the
same this unit model obviously we can
use it on city scans we can use on USGS
ultrasonic rams this one and we can use
it on a spine city scan we can use this
on even us
a national image if you take it with the
picture so it's showing whether if it's
mole is a carcinogenic or not so once
you have trained those weights of this
model what you can do is you can just
change the input set keep most because
we have already trained it on a medical
data set it knows the how medical data
sets work how actually the color and the
hue of medical images will change so you
can keep like instead of two you can
keep for layer it's Contin same and then
train maybe the next four layers if it's
a eight layer network okay so that's how
it works we are trying to use
progressively so I usually imagine it on
diabetic retinopathy prediction and then
I'm using that initial weight trained
weight as the and fixing the four layer
rate and reducing the number of layers I
need to Train
so the more specific so if I've been
using so this these are where it will
work but the best will be if I'm using
another heroic fluorescent and
geographic image of a heart maybe
because it's the same color and hue so
it will be bam you just need to train
the last layer and it will work very
good okay okay so reusability of this
dcn and model I do not think I have time
but I'll try
so we can fine-tune imagine a trendy CNN
from medical image analysis as I showed
you we can find in the same image net
trained the CNN model in a completely
different domain and for a completely
different task okay so let's see how so
fashion image caption generation okay we
use the image net trendy CNN to learn
apparent classification with the style
which is known as ACS you can go and
look up ACS is a is a this data set
which actually has labeled fashion
images so you can train it on image net
pre-trained model like we did for
diabetic retinopathy prediction and and
get the image features through transfer
learning and fine tuning now that we
have the transfer learning and fine
tuning features available we fit it to a
record neural network okay so we then we
use along the LST M RN n on the learned
image features for image caption
generation it is a stateless it is a
stateful model it learns in cycles and
it's able to generate captions for you
using the features
that you retrieved from the images yes
the RNN model yeah I'll show you I'll
show you an image okay so similarly I do
image augmentation of a cloud and
similarly I do you know the rotation and
then the transfer learning as we as we
showed as you can already see in the
presentation itself there is overlap
that means the model is very easy to do
okay so the record neural network I'll
just define it one second the record
neural networks are networks with loops
and then allowing informations to
persist lsdm networks are a special kind
of RNN capable of learning long-term
dependencies so it can save the state so
good for state of state state wise step
by step caption generation tasks this
one what you would do I'm doing is I'm
feeding the image to a Google net and
doing the D CNN Google net is what does
the DCN a deep conditioner after taking
it to a LS TM layer and learning in
stages so first level and I get a
prediction task i when i forward it i
forward the information in the lsdm
feature layer and the predicted task
okay
I've in here when I forward I forward
this one and this one okay so and it
keeps saves the my predicted tasks in
the earlier layer takes it to the next
layer learn more features modified the
modifies the attack then takes the
predicted tag and the and some more
feature and does it in different
sections okay this is the asus image
caption generation thing so actually the
one the deep CNN the CNN which I showed
you we do it we then generate labels
using RNN and the generated tag for each
stage our velvet blouse uniform red and
checks okay so the caption generation I
train the model and I tried to generate
caption using imaginate trained RNN
google net and then feed it without any
transfer learning and fine tuning this
image gave me just to insert I okay but
when I actually applied fine-tuning and
transfer learning on actual ACS image
set trained it on ACS image set you
the imagenet prenatal protein model
weights it came gave me Jersey t-shirt
for upper body suit of clothes
okay so much much better much better
type of prediction so it actually is
getting that there are two types of
clothes there is t-shirt for upper body
and there is suit of clothes so there it
actually recognizes two different things
and tries to combine them and give the
prediction out okay and there is
obviously Microsoft cognitive services
and api's please they'll go and play
with it I do not have time to do the
demo but it's really very cool feel free
to drop an email my deck has my email if
you have questions about cognitive api's
and bots all the model that I showed you
is just a one click thing because we
have just released it and any software
developer can actually use it so play
with it have fun and times and I'm ready
to take any questions yes yes because it
actually it's better to because I said
the aspect ratio should be the same so
if it's same then it's always square
right so it's 50 by 50 never adieu 5500
when you can but it will actually mess
up your color and yeah yeah yeah so it's
better not to do it yes
mmm-hmm how is it different from and
what would you feed the oil STM yes
that's what I'm doing Google net is
doing the Google net is actually doing
the doing the image pre-processing thing
the extraction the feature so what it
actually does it fine Tunes it for you
and transfer learns so while training
the D CNN as I showed in diabetic
retinopathy prediction here also I'm
taking the ACS fashion image I'm trying
to do transfer learning and fine tuning
so maybe I'm training just the last two
three layers and it reduces that step a
lot that's all no no it learns in stages
so it's not the same weights every time
you predict something out in one layer
you actually are you actually are so the
the convolution network is one thing you
do it first and then the final whole
feature space you transfer to the LS TM
and the LST and what it does it actually
tries to do it in stacks right so it
first learns and predicts something then
the next time it goes it actually takes
the project tag along with it and then
learns on new features just one second
yeah it learns on new features and get
the predicts Newton and combines it with
the predicted earlier version Freddie
attack and predicts a new tag and then
again tags it along so that's how it
tries to create so it it knows about the
check the checked blouse that I showed
you it well it would talk about it's a
read checked uniform so it learns about
read it learns about checks it learns
about uniform so it can then combine all
three and say I think it's a woman
wearing I did not put any personal
information in there but you I'm the one
which we made available or the cognitive
API if you go and play with it it will
tell you I think it's a woman wearing
checks uniform so yeah yes yeah yes yes
yes
now so I'll give you an example where
this is actually used it is used the one
which I described for the for the stroke
thing so it's being used in emergency
rooms so there is our our DHA DHA is
also using it planning to use it Vic
there there is very less availability of
doctors there is first just first aid
medical caregivers so suppose you have
your own field you have very restricted
medical facility just you have an MRI
MRI machine and the room is maybe one
doctor in a remote place handling the
whole whole thing everybody so it's very
difficult for doctors to come if I have
a stroke you are brought into the field
you just go through an MRI and then you
are placed in the in the emergency room
for hours before somebody can even start
or initiate the treatment there can be
two types of stroke there can be a clot
that can be a hemorrhage there are two
types of agents you can give a clot can
give a thinning agent and the hemorrhage
will need a clotting agent if you have a
clot if you give a clotting agent if
your predict wrong and you give a
clotting agent the person dies instantly
so in that case the doctors the doctors
input is very essential yes I'll go just
once again yeah so the doctors input is
very essential but it actually helps the
nurses you know to give a smaller doses
of TPA attaining agent they if the the
Machine says I think of the software
they feed the draw MRI to the to the
software and says I think it's a nun 99%
sure it's a clot then the nursing agent
can act learners can actually give a
cleaning agent just to start the process
and stop the person from dying
yes yeah okay so I'll I'll just stop
here maybe I will take your questions
out saying
you